Caption: okay sir and thanks for coming to listen
Caption: to me performance of immediate for the
Caption: next 45 minutes so basically I didn't
Caption: talk basically because I got dared to
Caption: buy the DVD Melbourne Twitter account so
Caption: yeah I submitted this kind of the joke
Caption: and then got voted in and then they got
Caption: voted in here so everybody hates me and
Caption: wants me to make a fool of myself in
Caption: public so my records I think is done to
Caption: miss pross to conferences on a day now I
Caption: have to go mental coming from public so
Caption: thanks for coming to say that before I
Caption: get salad and thanks called sponsors and
Caption: the events can't happen without them
Caption: because you know they're not cheeks put
Caption: on and without answers to put up the
Caption: money and you will be paying a lot more
Caption: or be doing something terrible intent on
Caption: the weekend let's just mean to you and
Caption: when somebody wants that so good about
Caption: me um I'm and exculpation above my
Caption: friends of Western Australia so um I
Caption: recently moved to Melbourne even much
Caption: nicer [ __ ] he doesn't die 6:00 p.m. I
Caption: strongly recommend you won't move there
Caption: I was asked by my tech ladybug head
Caption: remove this port point to the Milton
Caption: version found not been expecting
Caption: developers insulate no it needs which
Caption: might be officially old and it also need
Caption: is the internship says that what matters
Caption: okay so I've mostly worked online a
Caption: different systems so take everything
Caption: that I say in the context of my
Caption: experiences and these days I mostly work
Caption: on back inside
Caption: so the last time I did any series in my
Caption: HTML it was still okay to lay everything
Caption: out using tables I did those days those
Caption: days were I am NOT doing CSS
Caption: I'm just not and I've been on projects
Caption: that went very well I've been on pretty
Caption: badly fortunately I've never done
Caption: anything really about it did you think
Caption: so why am I doing this talk so either
Caption: print suggests that I was running myself
Caption: down by submitting the topic but I don't
Caption: actually agree I think it's an in-stream
Caption: focus way too much on the view journey
Caption: and negative comments are reserved for
Caption: people who are doing other stuff that we
Caption: don't personally like because it's not
Caption: our style I think that ignore some
Caption: fundamental truths I think that
Caption: everybody makes mistakes and failure is
Caption: one of the best ways to learn things so
Caption: I want to encourage people to be
Caption: appropriately self-critical and I'm kind
Caption: of leading by example so this talk is
Caption: actually all about me me my ego please
Caption: everything in is talking on the same I
Caption: mean is criticizing other people is
Caption: beauty looks fun but most people I could
Caption: criticize aren't here there are a few of
Caption: them hi guys I'm reach for instant and
Caption: get me at the pub later but you know
Caption: criticizing poppin could get me attacked
Caption: by lawyers more so more seriously if you
Caption: can't admit are the areas where you need
Caption: to improve you're not going to be able
Caption: to do so so every talk at the contents
Caption: next buzz words these are my buzz words
Caption: I've not met my husband corner and
Caption: you're not getting saying it buzz words
Caption: again
Caption: so I'm on Durant so back when I first
Caption: started before MBC before webforms
Caption: for.net itself my club West Berlin
Caption: platform was called classic ASP now we
Caption: didn't call the classic ASP at the time
Caption: most like World War one walking called
Caption: World War one at the time and much as a
Caption: reason so pretty much everything you bad
Caption: you've ever heard about that decay is
Caption: team's true in the lives actually the
Caption: lines and at the time I was a very
Caption: junior developer with excessive
Caption: confidence and it had a consumer vision
Caption: and a static ASP cause and it really was
Caption: and never underestimate the ability of a
Caption: junior developer make things worse and I
Caption: did so I was looking for ways books has
Caption: been better
Caption: and I thought what I thought was the
Caption: answer in a Microsoft example project is
Caption: all fooling skipper
Caption: laughs from the audience so the others
Caption: make the suicide and involve building
Caption: business systems I'm using a business
Caption: plan and a data layer component in
Caption: everybody's favorite language DBT such
Caption: basic premise when you have a type like
Caption: a pea coat with all of the basics
Caption: component business a component and how
Caption: to do all that data access through a
Caption: baby chicks data access component and it
Caption: taken Microsoft certain must be good
Caption: architecture so I then proceeded to
Caption: apply this to everything so it'll kind
Caption: of like this so you had your cutting
Caption: edge be website running up really old
Caption: version is and it had the BB six
Caption: business layer and the data access layer
Caption: and then finally got the darkest fears
Caption: now clearly this is better than just
Caption: having cutting-edge because it's got
Caption: layers and now mean everybody muscle a
Caption: is now I don't want to sound like let me
Caption: get separation of concerns because
Caption: that's very important we're putting
Caption: business logic into zb6
Caption: like this is hard limit X doesn't make
Caption: it easy to pass on complex data
Caption: structures and it makes the dev cycle a
Caption: lot longer
Caption: so practice business play in almost all
Caption: cases create an instance of the data
Caption: active component and then for the
Caption: whatever call have got straight on to
Caption: the database that added no value of the
Caption: number that says component does a query
Caption: against a database and because the
Caption: record set that gives all the way back
Caption: again and just to have a separation of
Caption: the query from the business logic but
Caption: cleaning the bbc's component in nearly
Caption: water is as over at my commencement so
Caption: pleasant listening white code because
Caption: it's actually adding value to your
Caption: project
Caption: gravity is demanding in writing
Caption: significant amount of code that adds no
Caption: value then your architecture gives the
Caption: segment the value of an architecture is
Caption: not determined by where it comes from
Caption: and the promoters the field Authority is
Caption: like a logical fallacy and an extremely
Caption: common reason for doing architecture all
Caption: female our visits are bringing says that
Caption: and quite often they do and but
Caption: expertise is a reason to consider some
Caption: documents if you still need to actually
Caption: consider their documents and it's really
Caption: common to actually can ignore the caveat
Caption: that experts will put on their
Caption: architectures and my place not
Caption: applicable in X and you go can apply to
Caption: it anyway because you heard that the
Caption: headline
Caption: X's right foot Y and a little forth in a
Caption: heat and then you say but I fold it the
Caption: experts um and then you can find anyone
Caption: so pretty common to implement a
Caption: misunderstanding of an architecture
Caption: rather than actually implementing an
Caption: architecture
Caption: properly because going and looking at
Caption: active reading into their data takes a
Caption: while and tedious and boring in the
Caption: focus that things to do is one pineapple
Caption: in extremities and also junior
Caption: developers do stupid things as you know
Caption: what's important now we've all done this
Caption: it's a normal part of the learning
Caption: process and there's a thing you develop
Caption: it your job to correct to your
Caption: developers without you know
Caption: you know field stupid or crushing new
Caption: enthusiasm if you were there once
Caption: everybody goes through it so taking
Caption: examples this is about mid last decade
Caption: working on a line of business system for
Caption: government department and this would
Caption: even meant the entire process required
Caption: to support piece of legislation it was
Caption: based on a workflow engine for parking
Caption: with another company and we just didn't
Caption: know any better and I look to a pretty
Caption: tight six-month deadline so it was
Caption: defined by the legislation I went live
Caption: on time and clients actually buy happy
Caption: with it I miss system even won some
Caption: fairly minor awards so it'd be quite
Caption: easy to talk business market wind and
Caption: move on or there's no happy client award
Caption: yeah everything great project so that it
Caption: looks though a number of potential areas
Caption: for improvement in building this project
Caption: than in other circumstances if we're not
Caption: being quite so lucky could have
Caption: completely derailed it so we implemented
Caption: this with a web font observant Yui and
Caption: we have an application server the
Caption: person's web services and we used for
Caption: more business actions do without er
Caption: access and that also hosted our workflow
Caption: engines and we had some other components
Caption: that aren't directly relevant here to
Caption: connect our systems so why did we have
Caption: separate webinar creation service well
Caption: it was the style at the time and
Caption: Industry to have never benefit to the
Caption: minimal security benefits to separating
Caption: this around and also a difference in how
Caption: we need to scale in and components we're
Caption: putting on either of them but meant we
Caption: had a lot of layers we had all um we
Caption: have client side UI and web server UI
Caption: logic and what's a business logic and
Caption: then we have client connects to the
Caption: backend and then we have back-end web
Caption: services and business logic and this
Caption: data access I own an extremely anemic
Caption: domain model and then eventually we have
Caption: a database
Caption: occasionally
Caption: [Music]
Caption: current another protesting uncountable a
Caption: momentum so this wasn't mixed just
Caption: having mini layers and every single
Caption: operation we did have to go through all
Caption: of these Labor's so every single query
Caption: and every single business logic
Caption: operation had to have one of these
Caption: things in Shaanxi ated and had an
Caption: additional web service course and so
Caption: most of the plays didn't actually do
Caption: very much for that overhead
Caption: so we basically separated the web
Caption: applications open a business as a server
Caption: introducing unnecessary on network all
Caption: and that introduces additional latency
Caption: but it also introduces an additional
Caption: risk of failure we also have a one to
Caption: one foot issues with the design of our
Caption: API so we had a standard set of videos
Caption: that we used by the web api that means
Caption: that the same representation of the
Caption: interview can be used in every single
Caption: case it's not exactly saving the
Caption: entities themselves across the wire but
Caption: it's really impossible because most
Caption: users don't actually need all the data
Caption: on those entities or they needed an
Caption: alternate format is quite inefficient
Caption: for attending a lot more stuff around
Caption: then you actually need to be the vehicle
Caption: to folks if the client and server have
Caption: different understandings which part of
Caption: the data that you populated in this
Caption: particular call we can bother sending
Caption: that field because they don't need is
Caption: that they don't need it now now from no
Caption: reference exception that's not a great
Caption: way to run a railroad and the
Caption: temperament inspires the business server
Caption: to Beit repeaters be a pro to us and
Caption: quite services are an ATM they're
Caption: extremely chatty
Caption: we already have also a more secure or
Caption: more performant or more stable and more
Caption: flexible projects and we call it the
Caption: database and some very very smart people
Caption: work on making that a very great
Caption: platform and we're basically slapping a
Caption: layer hoarding operative code
Caption: approximate so really and then we come
Caption: to this
Caption: so at the time we did perfect I didn't
Caption: know if in high night and I'm not
Caption: actually entirely sure it actually
Caption: existed at the time I didn't like yeah I
Caption: won't know him because everybody should
Caption: do that um yeah um I had read tons of
Caption: education at Kentucky great book and I
Caption: look like a porter and so long story
Caption: short I wrote my own room Aaron and I
Caption: including the client project um it was
Caption: pretty proven it it requires a lot of
Caption: custom code for each map entity I'm you
Caption: need to manually flying into the dirty
Caption: you need to still write a favor to
Caption: sequel yourself and they didn't really
Caption: support custom queries particular world
Caption: um so the interesting exercise but it
Caption: should never fall into production
Caption: episode but I had any bug unit in how it
Caption: implemented many community collections
Caption: not a great way to represent entities
Caption: but we had a lot of the minister declare
Caption: design and this buzz would never hit in
Caption: happy Holi application if you use do is
Caption: our own but as I've moved on
Caption: the support team working migrations will
Caption: be used it and they hit above and it
Caption: wiped out all the associations between a
Caption: whole bunch of entities if actually
Caption: deleted them all network wasn't back and
Caption: something complained of dirty anything
Caption: from the back um so that was fun that
Caption: was a really fun support call to get to
Caption: the team fortunately they hadn't
Caption: actually done a live on production we
Caption: have various others blackouts and so
Caption: anyone against that was an interesting
Caption: course
Caption: so yes other poems um so we got the
Caption: system round of workflow engine and in
Caption: order to participate in transactions
Caption: without worth 500 or your code needs to
Caption: be registered in wonderful Microsoft
Caption: you can reverse that introduced a
Caption: registration step after booking
Caption: application service solutions and if you
Caption: forgot to do that step and sometimes
Caption: everything would work and sometimes it
Caption: wouldn't there's a lot of friction to
Caption: the drilling process we already had two
Caption: solutions and the whole world of low
Caption: value layers so more friction what's an
Caption: exacting formula and on least one
Caption: occasion I had I rented to complain to
Caption: my coworker by getting angry and telling
Caption: them essentially through hard enough and
Caption: I really owe people apology to that
Caption: because I should not have done their way
Caption: to that friction could have been reduced
Caption: but I didn't implement any of them
Caption: because you know I was doing I was
Caption: actively ignoring feedback from my
Caption: co-workers on that the architect had a
Caption: defect they were telling me that I was
Caption: not reacting to that feedback and that
Caption: was partly because I donated work on
Caption: that stuff
Caption: pre dealing outputting a lot of
Caption: infrastructure stuff so you purchased me
Caption: as a significant issue now the time it
Caption: would have taken me to fix that wood
Caption: paper took many times over in reduce
Caption: overhead for the rest of the scene so
Caption: lesson five don't distribute without
Caption: reason adding communication verb in it
Caption: and the different failure point has to
Caption: be something you can justify with
Caption: concrete answers if in general you're
Caption: going to see more weight into
Caption: distributor logic horizontally great
Caption: house different areas of functionality
Caption: rather than separating out your
Caption: different vertical layers this is not
Caption: staged blue moon entirely synchronous
Caption: models but it's basically an argument to
Caption: be intelligence about leaving your
Caption: boundaries where that will be depends on
Caption: your cooking classification
Caption: just think about them don't just put in
Caption: an application server everybody has when
Caption: they tell you your models to be you
Caption: since recently do it is massively
Caption: massively accelerated
Caption: defining a de o is easy and thick and
Caption: with learn more key columns much they
Caption: have very very low maintenance over
Caption: a mapping directly into the format you
Caption: actually use and need is significantly
Caption: much more efficient more expressive and
Caption: less error-prone doesn't call the
Caption: confusion of to what parts of the model
Caption: is actually populated or what the and
Caption: operation needs structural similarity no
Caption: reason to share models the couples
Caption: public functionality that you may wish
Caption: to separate all very independently in
Caption: future German could be restricted to
Caption: basically only the very low-level data
Caption: types and it generally needs to be
Caption: something that's actually consistent
Caption: everywhere maybe an exact format but
Caption: there aren't very many other examples in
Caption: one system there are relatively few
Caption: models that are actually going to be
Caption: treated like that as an atomic unit
Caption: don't like frameworks unless you really
Caption: really need to some like a framework and
Caption: I'm running an hour a mile of fun
Caption: exercise I look successful and that
Caption: being honestly wasn't anything in what
Caption: would qualify as a real production
Caption: quality RA who would basically
Caption: convoluted data access layer with
Caption: delusions of grandeur writing framework
Caption: doesn't add business value they may need
Caption: an able to deliver better to better
Caption: deliver business value with other code
Caption: but you need to be able to actually
Caption: justify that doing that very long and
Caption: hard before you are building alternative
Caption: things that exist and also consider
Caption: where you actually need them in the
Caption: first place a standard you know one of
Caption: the mill directors Laden or and
Caption: component or probably exists is programs
Caption: a lot better and also we have to see
Caption: that feedback is necessary correct
Caption: errors and everything has errors we
Caption: don't acknowledge or errors you can fix
Caption: them in and they accumulate over time
Caption: now and not picking architectures has
Caption: significant cost in terms of wasted
Caption: effort and increase defects so when
Caption: people you see that record also develop
Caption: teams succeed or fail collectively
Caption: no one cares house when your code is if
Caption: the system doesn't work it's really easy
Caption: to get siloed I'm doing this thing and
Caption: everyone else can go to hell
Caption: that doesn't help getting all your
Caption: things done look expensive your team
Caption: team members in our profession and
Caption: working well in a team is key developer
Caption: skill so I would really attend X
Caption: development or you're just putting all
Caption: your work on a future maintenance
Caption: intelligence so two point five letters
Caption: of the previous system which you know
Caption: was written with certain we involved in
Caption: couples other similar projects these
Caption: were not successful many of the factors
Caption: in that don't be for me personally I'm
Caption: not going to go over but they were a few
Caption: things and so so one project had water
Caption: requirements that we know performing
Caption: accidents in the system and one way that
Caption: you can order everything that somebody
Caption: does is to popularity between servers
Caption: servers using Kerberos and log
Caption: everything so I had that extra sense
Caption: that it can be done
Caption: I mean domain recommending it's almost
Caption: certainly bad idea to propagate your
Caption: user empty walkway down to database but
Caption: let's say you're like me and you
Caption: accidentally said you would do it in a
Caption: tender response and now you're kind of
Caption: stuck with it so we did that and you
Caption: could tell who did anything against the
Caption: database and now it's night we had some
Caption: all the tables populated by triggers and
Caption: don't that I look anyway your work fine
Caption: and everyone's developing scene okay and
Caption: and then we went to an environment of
Caption: more like production which we didn't get
Caption: immediately and that had more servers
Caption: and it did not work at all to the extent
Caption: that every single service call failed
Caption: which
Caption: so how many Kerberos works differently
Caption: between services that are all running on
Caption: the same machine versus services and
Caption: running on different machines with
Caption: culatta method getting that work
Caption: unfortunately we discover that very late
Caption: - a long time to get things working and
Caption: we should have changed approach that we
Caption: committed to it and we call the changing
Caption: our approach was difficult politically
Caption: which was not a good reason to make an
Caption: architectural decision so a different
Caption: messaging excellent for decoupling
Caption: components it removes your tackle
Caption: coupling allows required allotment
Caption: reordering pub/sub allows models where
Caption: an event-driven model where consumers
Caption: don't have to be known to this producer
Caption: it's also a terrible default for
Caption: consuming all commands in a system to
Caption: get a result is something that you
Caption: submit synchronously to acquire you can
Caption: poll you can notify the user a
Caption: synchronously such as by email or you
Caption: can lie to them and tell them that
Caption: something's being done and then just
Caption: hope it actually does succeed in the
Caption: background and none of those options are
Caption: particularly good and I'm holding is
Caption: expensive to implementer to run and I
Caption: think notifications are not always
Caption: appropriate to keeping in business
Caption: processes you don't really want to be
Caption: half way to really through filling out a
Caption: form you click Next and it will send you
Caption: an email when you can fill out the next
Caption: pages system that's not going to work
Caption: and why want to risk of distrust of
Caption: destroying user trust in the system
Caption: because the system is lying to them and
Caption: fairly hoping so XML
Caption: everyone loved XML last decade then
Caption: everyone was Jatin this decade and
Caption: we love next decade emoji hurt autism's
Caption: of any scale need some little
Caption: configuration and that tends to end up
Caption: in configuration files which in this
Caption: project were XML and a configuration
Caption: went slightly overboard we use or the
Caption: excellent you can't have any XML we've
Caption: used all of it on this project there's
Caption: no more left so in addition to your
Caption: standard web config with Microsoft
Caption: themselves we don't always connect demo
Caption: moving the network mobile web sites and
Caption: we had XML configuration to all of our
Caption: dependency injection everything within
Caption: the injected was completed by XML so we
Caption: have literally thousands of lines of XML
Caption: in fact you've never done this
Caption: specifying generic types in XML is not
Caption: fun and really really really easy to get
Caption: wrong and really really really hard to
Caption: get buzz when you do and it needed to be
Caption: modified every single time anybody out
Caption: of the service class which meant a lot
Caption: of people will modify anything that's
Caption: really easy to get Raman really hard to
Caption: debug so that's problematic positive
Caption: sort of merge conflicts which isn't
Caption: another source above so it's pretty much
Caption: guaranteed that people change something
Caption: incorrectly wait there's more yes and
Caption: also we also define all about very very
Caption: fine-grained permissions in XML so it
Caption: multiple roles and which services a role
Caption: could call we're determined by large XML
Caption: files and when I say services I mean
Caption: every single method at its own
Caption: configuration we're bypassing that
Caption: problem and that really excusing from
Caption: core services fine-grained permissions
Caption: on a primitive edges to get huge
Caption: overhead and it's really difficult to
Caption: change involved is what roles can do
Caption: changes or if you have a new role
Caption: remover all we merge them or split them
Caption: and yeah it's not fun at all so testing
Caption: architecture should be done in something
Caption: that actually will place in production
Caption: environments your laptop in most cases
Caption: doesn't
Caption: quite a collection is bones you should
Caption: do this early and you should do it
Caption: before you commit to that architecture
Caption: because once you commit to something it
Caption: gets really expensive to change
Caption: particulate there are contractual
Caption: restrictions on what you can do it you
Caption: need to make it as realistic so you
Caption: don't miss things and tapping on a
Caption: single machine is the completely
Caption: different security behavior that occurs
Caption: with multi machine and finding our 300
Caption: workers end of the project with your
Caption: deadline rapidly approaching is highly
Caption: unpleasant I don't recommend that
Caption: experience if you fighting system
Caption: consider a different approach rather
Caption: than continuing to bang on solution if
Caption: you perfect isn't working you
Caption: potentially got talking you can keep it
Caption: spending effort and I hope you somehow
Caption: get things to work even though you
Caption: haven't yet or even though this is not
Caption: going to happen
Caption: see if you can come to goal some other
Caption: way now security propagation problem had
Caption: a solution but took a lot of my time
Caption: took the time of contractor and also one
Caption: of our infrastructure people to find
Caption: that and that it could be much better
Caption: spent elsewhere
Caption: now also other ways we could have
Caption: accomplished the actual objective of the
Caption: client in a much more effective fashion
Caption: so we got stuck on a solution that
Caption: instead we could have been focusing on
Caption: satisfying the actual business
Caption: requirement use x equals messaging
Caption: judiciously idea to improve the
Caption: robustness and decreased coupling
Caption: horizontally we use it vertically
Caption: introduced it and that there are
Caption: benefits justify that additional cost an
Caption: exit synchronous communication
Caption: vertically both complex questions how to
Caption: do with semillas and client expectations
Caption: and result notification horizontally
Caption: between components we have known pattern
Caption: such as data queues but we have really
Caption: had those with vertical communication so
Caption: much is customization it's an order they
Caption: have an immediate expert expectation is
Caption: over receiving an order number with a
Caption: much more relaxed expectation or when
Caption: they will receive an order confirmation
Caption: email to this email on it
Caption: so they didn't consider submitting
Caption: Comanche music synchronously and
Caption: producing events other components
Caption: produce eight increment consumer rather
Caption: the tools was enjoying the request item
Caption: potent they can handle failure
Caption: conditions and spree time what a Mexican
Caption: figuration if you can write code to work
Caption: coming out to do that type standing word
Caption: we use our thousands of lines of XML to
Caption: a couple of lines of seizure with a
Caption: couple of additional lines for some of
Caption: the exceptions that can't be reached by
Caption: convention that would have been actively
Caption: masculine simple to maintain and in most
Caption: cases you could have just added server
Caption: classes without having to your any
Caption: configuration network order which have
Caption: been a huge game and development
Caption: efficiency they can configuration
Caption: students as soon as possible
Caption: [Music]
Caption: basically an order of preference
Caption: you should hardly think to delimit end
Caption: especially encourage things you can just
Caption: have an automatically for instance type
Caption: scanning and simply to do all your di
Caption: configuration then people think
Caption: consideration times at their clinic and
Caption: then last and most reluctantly you cool
Caption: things into a data store seen
Caption: significant figure one times every
Caption: configuration point in the potential
Caption: difference between your development and
Caption: production environments and therefore a
Caption: potential source of life so
Caption: so fine example it's a line of business
Caption: system to support core business
Caption: functions and this is basically a
Caption: pretentious way of saying it's a new
Caption: system to do important stuff that a
Caption: business relied upon and you would
Caption: booktubeathon entered and we had a lot
Caption: of them so many services and it was
Caption: built with no one business people have
Caption: worked with and your system is in use
Caption: currently and it's delivering seen
Caption: consistent values so that would mean
Caption: that you know everybody normal is ideal
Caption: and perfect so this hasn't had on the
Caption: order of hundred services that's quite a
Caption: lot of services and every single one of
Caption: these services is fundamentally the same
Caption: architecture and infrastructure
Caption: implementation and one is not a lot of
Caption: architectural styles for hundred
Caption: services I want to give strokin full
Caption: nice features were refined error
Caption: handling an automatic registration of
Caption: handlers and all kinds of wonderful fun
Caption: stuff
Caption: the single approach did not suit all
Caption: elements of system some things just need
Caption: several products some things need really
Caption: to edit domain modeling and some things
Caption: kind of end up in here so no one
Caption: architecture is going to capture the
Caption: requirement of every single element so
Caption: start building the infrastructure
Caption: I built the simplest domain that we had
Caption: so I can validate the infrastructure
Caption: work and I thought implemented as neat
Caption: as anemic domain model with transaction
Caption: scripts now it was easy to do that and
Caption: as the simplest domain we had for
Caption: communications logic in it
Caption: and then I call it good and I would want
Caption: to do other things and then the team we
Caption: want to do much more complex domain
Caption: using a simple domain that I built as a
Caption: template and it turns out the
Caption: transaction scripts don't scare world to
Caption: convert domains they didn't produce very
Caption: beautiful objects paper is poor models
Caption: that don't express business concept
Caption: clearly they on tribute business rules
Caption: are
Caption: in first Walter procedural code and so
Caption: Webster's finds everything's basically
Caption: no difference they can be actively
Caption: harmful to into the complex amount and
Caption: by the time this became a pound I've
Caption: locked into design features that make
Caption: switching to a richer domain model
Caption: problematic not impossible but more
Caption: elaborated than it should be so the axis
Caption: we have you identified service small
Caption: services really quite heavily generally
Caption: we had a single aggregate for their
Caption: service and this was based on how we
Caption: decided to implement some of the
Caption: fundamental design patterns of the
Caption: system and that's not without its costs
Caption: a lot more moving pieces to deployed
Caption: it's a lot more configuration it's a lot
Caption: more into service communication so we
Caption: really should approach more relative
Caption: concept in Africa concept book needs the
Caption: structure against the simplest domain
Caption: here we had more complex domains that
Caption: would have significant issues with some
Caption: of our implementation decision a more
Caption: complex process context will have
Caption: illustrated in our services which is
Caption: ingrained and potentially we have built
Caption: one simple service in isolation as a
Caption: proof of concept for system we've had
Caption: multiple complex services interacting
Caption: and that did not prove the concepts that
Caption: we actually needed to so each component
Caption: could have been built with an
Caption: architecture that actually matched its
Caption: requirements environment and importance
Caption: over Engineering has implementation
Caption: costs to be more expensive to deploy and
Caption: run and maintain bit under engineering
Caption: can also result in high B X and
Caption: therefore destination so other ways many
Caption: more maintaining an initial low quality
Caption: models don't really Express the domain
Caption: of fishermen they generally produce a
Caption: lot of duplicated procedural code that a
Caption: cleaner model will eliminate and ideally
Caption: you could do simple things as simple
Caption: services and more complex into the
Caption: complex services for that in quite well
Caption: you need to constrain stead of
Caption: architectures to choose from rather than
Caption: a single architecture that
Caption: not suitable for many of your cases so
Caption: major to microservices apart from the
Caption: abuse by market everywhere
Caption: is that it specifies the size of a
Caption: service in the name services should be
Caption: large enough to do something well and no
Caption: larger but specifying that there should
Caption: be micro tends to make you focus on how
Caption: can i cutting out reducers even if
Caption: lamenting for it something
Caption: how large something is and what do
Caption: depends on context has no real right
Caption: answer so a wrong answers so and making
Caption: every service into literally the
Caption: smallest possible thing is one of them
Caption: something naturally come together and it
Caption: makes sense to group things together
Caption: service so if you are the random things
Caption: um so we can circle fault frameworks and
Caption: fairly common trap and I'm solution and
Caption: now what's your problem I should have
Caption: actually said that if I had never made
Caption: it home with SharePoint I made it with
Caption: other things
Caption: oh so it's ok expected you'll be
Caption: familiar with particular tools and
Caption: frameworks that's part of your drug but
Caption: what's not okay is pulling the meteor
Caption: project immediately would happen to
Caption: learn apparently adding their values I'm
Caption: accept him Splinter overly complex
Caption: illusions that have more infrastructure
Caption: than the project actually wants and one
Caption: bleeding vendors in this space for many
Caption: issues of di containers di containers
Caption: are great and in many domains they add
Caption: an awful lot value but using them is not
Caption: free quite relatives to understand the
Caption: are conventions that are in use complex
Caption: registration can obscure how things
Caption: actually fit together and lead to errors
Caption: default assumptions and there's a very
Caption: simple program
Caption: the cost of using the making I wanted
Caption: maybe you should just use a ICN you know
Caption: continued dependence of any current in
Caption: addition to the fact that I wrote my own
Caption: and also very powerful tools and I have
Caption: massively over used them in particular
Caption: using iron so queries generally terribly
Caption: inefficient said large amount of time
Caption: trying to write simple queries in what
Caption: would be a simple query planner in I was
Caption: writing in sequel but I'm trying to use
Caption: the our own API so make them incredibly
Caption: incredibly difficult Thank You economy
Caption: so that's really not institution like to
Caption: do things and now LinkedIn making less
Caption: terrible but still not as effective to
Caption: many complex groups so quite often you
Caption: know what you're doing is just broad
Caption: sequel queries that elevation maps
Caption: training program and that's been quite
Caption: not famous out there for doing that now
Caption: that don't mean you to have to deal with
Caption: out yard of net that you can still write
Caption: a sequel quite efficiently so probably
Caption: would speak to the orange is the mix
Caption: feature called lazy loading so let me
Caption: I'll do that a lot
Caption: it's a really great way of ensuring that
Caption: you have to put up performance issues
Caption: inside a firm because you will use it
Caption: and you'll be fine all your production
Caption: on your development data set and then
Caption: you go into production and it's pulling
Caption: in half the database and your database
Caption: is a terabyte in some you meet in your
Caption: system pulled over and your own popular
Caption: and five
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so um it's also really great might have
Caption: coffee and data access users in your
Caption: presentation life because I think being
Caption: legally loaded way up and rendering the
Caption: page when you know it should be queried
Caption: already so we can query data base you
Caption: should basically retreat everything you
Caption: need in one operations
Caption: let's return a simple model that
Caption: conforms to the data format your users
Caption: actually means you pass that up and it's
Caption: done and you do no further database
Caption: operations so we often structure code
Caption: because we need to be able to test it
Caption: now the only reason your code is
Caption: structured the way it is is to enabled
Caption: testing that I might even started as
Caption: well the candidate that tends to produce
Caption: code with a large number of mocks
Caption: mocking frameworks are great for what
Caption: they do there are certain cases you
Caption: can't really pass without them but you
Caption: should not be defined for kinda blocks
Caption: out the rest of your system just to test
Caption: anything in isolation that's probably a
Caption: warning sign and destruction is not as
Caption: efficient including the warning signs
Caption: and I've got all of this stuff is
Caption: inheritance hierarchies in hex and how
Caption: much stuff do you need to setup that you
Caption: need to have a five level big
Caption: inheritance hierarchy to set up with
Caption: those pictures large constructors and
Caption: test classes that you've got a whole lot
Caption: of state and if you have to magically
Caption: remember how it works every time the
Caption: Esprit that's not going to be a fun
Caption: experience and having a lot more setup
Caption: code than code and use and test suggests
Caption: that you've got a very context for code
Caption: that isn't actually delivering all that
Caption: much other so um conventions
Caption: everybody loves arguing about Europe
Caption: where we should put our raters and where
Caption: we should put up spaces it up and you
Caption: statement you're inside this bracket so
Caption: nobody can compile it doesn't care and
Caption: I've called meetings and written
Caption: documents to define coding
Caption: and allegedly giving probe consistent
Caption: has a lot of value um telling developers
Caption: to tell is built right roughly in line
Caption: with language convention to Mexico
Caption: burrito if you can't read the code
Caption: embraces next to the if statement rather
Caption: on a new line there's something deeply
Caption: wrong we do and you know not just to
Caption: direct this publishing the around it so
Caption: don't feel reusable libraries little
Caption: fully reasonable opponent is hard
Caption: platform vendors will try and cover
Caption: fundamentals and you know the cases
Caption: where they don't think no people who
Caption: will provide you compose maybe the other
Caption: stuff and some of them may or may not be
Caption: watching this conference opens change
Caption: their line since Melbourne um so they
Caption: were what matters that development a lot
Caption: more than you're going to be able to
Caption: relive a poem happiest legal and mock
Caption: scenarios has to be sufficient when
Caption: easy-to-use
Caption: that's what using other scenarios has to
Caption: be maintainable code about can be fixing
Caption: continues its product involves and happy
Caption: should be maintained so that you're not
Caption: stuck with a normal version forever
Caption: controls all in Calvin code bases we
Caption: have an all learners and hibernate
Caption: that's from client 2008 and it's an
Caption: alpha but you can't change anything that
Caption: abuse in so many places it'll be like
Caption: three months of no value to replace it
Caption: that's not some situation um so it's not
Caption: tough together estimated to naturally on
Caption: top of the petals of an impetus and it
Caption: was really what about degree well and
Caption: the clients or result tended to be
Caption: inflexible poorly maintained and
Caption: generally not worth the effort of using
Caption: inside that's a pretty shot
Caption: alone so you must take the taxi better
Caption: to copy code between projects than
Caption: extracted into a third project that
Caption: everyone's going to magically maintain
Caption: that makes me only to and responsibility
Caption: for that code clear and your project you
Caption: own it you maintain
Caption: if somebody puts in a third party
Caption: project well that's practically their
Caption: comments nobody gives ahead it also
Caption: allows you to extensively customize the
Caption: code you'll be using without having to
Caption: wire that you're breaking into everybody
Caption: else so I think we're almost at time so
Caption: key points practice it back
Caption: most of my failures involve downplaying
Caption: or ignoring to feedback from either the
Caption: difficulty of working systems or
Caption: directly from coworkers ensure that
Caption: every element of your architectures and
Caption: justify selves so as things just because
Caption: that's the way you do things
Caption: does largely follow a silo workflow and
Caption: don't push the sign up it's on to
Caption: everything that you do it and learn from
Caption: the fact is take your ego you can't look
Caption: at something you've done and suggest
Caption: ways of doing it better and it's really
Caption: time to find a new profession
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: we might have a couple minutes
Caption: you mentioned uploading your own
Caption: commercial code which thank you PL are
Caption: consume your images of dollars for
Caption: certain projects
Caption: what suggesting is that don't find
Caption: writing to use reasonably from the
Caption: beginning so if you're not going to get
Caption: correctly how they go to use it somebody
Caption: else in your organization put in their
Caption: projects that would be useful in yours
Caption: grab it pull it in you own it now these
Caption: it turns out that teams you know they've
Caption: evolved in kind of the same way and
Caption: there is actually opportunity to
Caption: consolidate those and you have the
Caption: structures in place to actually deal
Caption: with that the exciting project and
Caption: mentor project and maintain it and keep
Caption: it consistent and it won't divert
Caption: through other projects which is a whole
Caption: bunch of conditions on it then it might
Caption: be worth doing such but you know a
Caption: number of organizations have created
Caption: reasonable web libraries in the past and
Caption: generally they don't go very far and you
Caption: know I don't want to make mention
Caption: patents and practices as being terrible
Caption: people to this they're not about me but
Caption: you know let's just pretend I didn't um
Caption: I'm a big kind of doing that now
Caption: obviously you need to make sure you have
Caption: the appropriate or forest or ization
Caption: because most people won't work you can
Caption: self will have a contract in places that
Caption: everything you own belongs to your
Caption: employer and putting an apple in hub
Caption: under and as your license might be
Caption: slightly in violation of that a lot of
Caption: organizations are getting better at
Caption: saying yes we opened ourselves I've
Caption: worked to a number of organizations and
Caption: currently do that have no issue
Caption: reporting things that aren't
Caption: specifically the things that there isn't
Caption: earlier comes open sourcing now don't
Caption: expect
Caption: you open it up and many of you will get
Caption: a community and people will maintain
Caption: your coat for you because you know most
Caption: of the time what will give a disgrace
Caption: and you might have one person who looked
Caption: at the project and thought that was cool
Caption: and went on to something else but
Caption: basically that in most cases you can
Caption: doing that that really no extra cost in
Caption: or consulting it and I would be a fan
Caption: that but you know you can't just
Caption: arbitrarily decide to do it on your own
Caption: and that's your goal anything else all
Caption: we get on to what me go
Caption: [Applause]